hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse orange comm and in this video
we're going to go over the scale of how
to place electrodes for a 12-lead EKG
now before you get started you need to
get your supplies and what you need for
supplies is some electrodes you will
need ten of them and electrodes look
like this and they have a backing on the
back you will need some alcohol prep to
clean the skin and remove oils you also
need some exfoliation paper
I call it sandpaper on that looks like
tape because you're going to rough the
top layer of the skin up so what you do
is you clean your landmark areas and
then with alcohol prep and then you take
exfoliation paper and you lightly go
back and forth just to rough up that top
layer of skin and then you place the
electrode in the place where it needs to
go now if you have a patient who has a
lot of hair on their chest on the
landmarks of where your EKG stickers
need to go you need to trim those hairs
because it will cause artifact and also
be sure to watch out for any pacemakers
sub-q ports anything like that because
you'll want to remove the you'll not
want to put a sticker over those places
now some key things to remember about
your electrode make sure that they are
not expired because if they are expired
and you will get a bad connection and
also a lot of times I've had whenever
I've removed the backing of the
electrode off the gel that's on the
electrode was really dry and that caused
artifact and I didn't get a good
connection so make sure that they're
stored properly and that they're not
expired so let me demonstrate for you on
a mannequin how to place these 12-lead
EKG and what landmarks you use okay we
have our mannequin and what we're going
to do is you need to prep the chest
first so what you're going to do is take
your alcohol prep and clean your
landmarked areas and then you'll take
your exfoliation paper and just barely
scrape the skin on your landmarks areas
which will go
here in a second and remember if this
patient had a hairy chest you would want
to trim the hair on the chest you want
to avoid going over any implanted
devices like sub-q pores pacemakers icds
anything like that and if they have a
medication patch you don't want to go
over the medication patch so first what
we're going to do is we're going to
place our arm leads now you can use your
left right arms and lower legs but you
can also use the chest and since this
thumbing doesn't have in the arms or
legs we're going to use the chest so
first what we're going to place we're
going to place our right arm lis and
you're going to find the clavicle and
you're just going to go right below the
clavicle so we've prepped in everything
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take the backing off of the electrode
make sure these are not dry make sure
they're nice and lubricated because if
they're dry you'll get artifact and
you're just going to put it on the skin
and make sure it's nice and flesh on it
then we're going to go to the left arm
lead and we're going to find our
clavicle and we're just going to go
right below it make sure you're not
going over in any implanted devices
because that's really where they like to
be we're going to we've already prepped
so we're just going to place that over
there now let's go to our lower arm
leads we're going to go to the right
lower leg and for that you can go in the
upper right area of the quadrant so here
on this mannequin it is right here
so we're just going to place that there
and then we're going to go to the left
arm lead so we're going to go in the
left upper quadrant for that area as
well now let's do our chest leads first
what we're going to start with is v1
you're going to find the sternum which
is in the middle then you're going to
count the ribs and we're going to go to
the fourth intercostal space right of
the sternum so you're going to count as
ribs so about right here would be our
fourth intercostal space and that is
going to be v1 now let's place v2
we're going to go left to the sternum
and we're going to go to the fourth
intercostal space and it should be right
beside over to the left of where
everyone is so v2 will be right here and
we're going to skip v4
I mean v3 and we're going to go to v4
because v3 will be placed in between v2
and v4 so v4 is the fifth intercostal
space midclavicular so you're going to
find the clavicle the middle of the
clavicle and you're going to go down to
the fifth intercostal space which will
be right here and that's going to be v4
and now we're ready for v3 and this is
midway between v2 and v4 so v3 will be
right here and we're going to place that
here and now we're going to skip to b6
and we'll come back to v5 and these six
will be right here and it is going to be
mid axillary and it's going to be the
same level as v4 which is right here so
you're going to find the armpit and
you're going to go in between in the
middle of where the armpit is so about
right here on the patient lining it up
with v4 so right here is where it'd be
six to beat and now we're going to go to
b5 and this is the anterior axillary
line so it's not mid-axillary line like
v6 its anterior absolute axillary line
and it's the same level as v4 and v6 so
it will go in between that okay and now
you were done you have your right arm
left arm right leg left leg you have v1
v2 v3 v4 v5 and v6 so that is how you
place lectroids
for a 12-lead
Keiji okay so that is how you place 12
lead EKG electrodes on a patient be sure
to check out my other nursing skill
videos and subscribe to this YouTube
channel thank you so much for watching